[Music]
let's go out to atlanta georgia and talk
to our good friend adam adam how are we
doing man man
doing very well how about yourselves
outstanding how can we help man
well i got a question i've been fairly
familiar with y'all's
show with dave ramsey i didn't start
listening to those youtube videos
for past two or three months um
i've been hearing more and more about
stay out of debt and everything like
that and i've been slowly adopting that
idea into my mind
now i know that you mentioned about
paying off
debt accepts the house for a while if
the goal is to get out of debt
mind you i'm not a homeowner but if your
goal is to get out of debt
why save up for a down payment on the
house to get into a debt for a home
and if you are to get into debt to get a
home home how do you do that without
getting a credit score or anything like
that ah great question man
i like the way you're thinking already
two three months into the game
uh man well welcome to the team and uh
hopefully you you can adopt all the way
into the game
uh but to answer your first part of your
question why do we suggest
that you have a down payment to get back
into debt
uh our suggestion is not for you to jump
back into debt our number one suggestion
is if you could pay cash for your
mortgage
pay cash for it that is the best and our
preferred option
but we do understand that the average
person in america
is not going to save up four five six
hundred thousand dollars
to purchase a home and so we believe
that is okay to purchase a home because
for the most part that is an asset
and so we also want you to get into that
very very
wisely so you can get out of it very
quickly so you save to put 10 to 20
percent down
finances over 15 years and then boom
because we've also learned that the
average millionaire
person who has a net worth of a million
or more pays off their home mortgage
within a matter of 11
years so when you get that 15-year
fixed-rate mortgage
more than likely you'll pay that thing
off in between seven and 11 years
so then on the flip side if you have no
debt
like myself and like john and like the
other personalities that we have here
how do you get a you know how do you get
a mortgage without
actually having any any debt great
question this
is called manual underwriting
we fully endorse and i personally use
them
myself and they're called churchill
mortgage
so they don't really go by my credit
score they go by
you know did i pay my last mortgage on
time did i pay my
rent on time if i was renting they would
ask you to bring in your electricity
bill they will ask you to bring in stuff
and they will manually underwrite you
and look at your
your situation so and it's not and
churchill mortgage
is the one who we prefer now there are
several others out there who do manual
underwriting so that's not just one
particular bank
there are banks out there who do it but
churchill from our studying and our
relationship over the last few years
they're the best one to do it so you can
get a mortgage without having debt
a mortgage still is debt let me be real
with you
mortgage is still debt but that is
one debt that we are okay with um our
our team our tribe
um our followers and our our loved ones
to have uh because
if they do it our way the average person
would get out of it within between seven
and 11 years
make sense
adam you still there good man
well we lost him that's all right all
right let's go out to let me ask you
this
um adam you still there
yeah i'm here okay there we go sorry
great so did that make sense
yeah it did make sense and i was just
curious because i've been
personally burned figuratively by debt
and i'm
just want to stay away with him as much
as as much as possible so
hence hence the question good for you
yeah i mean and i'll tell you this adam
i just took out a mortgage i've been
renting i haven't owed anybody money in
years
and i just took out a mortgage and it
already is hanging on me
i've already had a meeting with my boss
here to how can we accelerate
i mean it's already weighing on me and
so it's not debt that we love
in fact we hate it it's something that
we tolerate just because
of how hard it is to save up for that
long to
to pay cash for a house yeah so it's not
preferable
um but it's the only one we'll tolerate
and it's even that it's with
with a really wrinkled up face right
yeah it has
the key word tolerate that's right
that's right yeah
yeah but i appreciate your call and man
welcome aboard like anthony said